moving on to the next line in our code
we see that running the new saga
function should have the effect of
creating a new execution context so that
it can make room for new variables that
are local to that function call then the
new context will become the interpreters
new current context for as long as that
function is running this first line will
add a new variable to the current scope
the next line adds another variable to
the read scope this time holding a
function value at this point will have
to do a lookup on the saga variable in
order to know which function these
parens are attempting to call the
interpreter handles this by checking
whether the name saga has any meaning in
its current context the read context the
interpreter checks the scope of the
current execution context and finds that
the saga variable is available locally
in that read scope the value found there
is a function object and the parens next
to the word saga tell the interpreter to
invoke that function running the saga
function will build a new execution
context and move the interpreters lookup
focus into it the first line adds a new
variable to that local scope and now we
do lookups on all three of our variables
again the interpreter will do this by
scanning outward from its current
context looking for the closest
containing context that can satisfy a
requested name first it goes looking for
hero which can't be found in the
containing context and so it falls
through falling through to the read
context the interpreter does not find a
hero variable there either finally
falling all the way through to the
global context the variable is found
there the string being logged is
beginning to get built up next it goes
looking for the deed variable what will
be the output of that lookup